you
hi so I'm going to talk about making
assistant part of our work though I am
by no means an expert and accessibility
my gmail ever have short company cobbler
and I also recently started a women who
code NYC chapter and IM engage in
chicago as my twitter handle inside i'm
only mushing that because i got see
talking note on the way here and i got
to yell out so why are we targeting when
we talk about accessibility we're
basically targeting anybody
doesn't have a mouth to rely solely on a
keyboard or a three meter or some some
some type of it assistive technology
what I'm not going to talk about our
techniques I've been around for a really
long time things like skip navigation
links and labels muscle I'm not gonna
talk about statistic like there's a lot
of data out there about this arrest
already so hopefully I'm just going to
show you just a few easy ways to build
components common components
oppressively so Ra stands for accessible
rich Internet applications and a face be
a set of rows states of properties that
help us build web pages excessively so
one role is the easiest one to use and
that's the main role and that in case
for the contents
yes this might be as did in your
application and you might already be
using the Maytag and if you are using
the main site of you should still
specify this role because there's a lot
of a lot of screen readers let users
navigate based on with another role is a
tooltip and some rolls have requirements
and four strokes of the on requirement
is to use the Aria described I attribute
and that just indicate
II like the element that contained the
description for the tooltip and I have
some examples so this is a pretty
typical use
a resolution and
you'll see that i'm specifying the role
tooltip i'm using the required attribute
which points to an ID that contains the
content and when you focus when you use
your focuses on this input element the
screen reader is going to read this
label first then it's going to
a tooltip and it's going to read the
content of the tooltip and then it's
going to indicate to the user that they
have to input text I know another row is
the dialogue this will have a few more
requirements so you need to specify are
you Layla by which is going to be the
title of your dialogue and artists for a
guy which in this case is going to be
instructions for the dialogue you also
have to make at least one element
focusable that's usually going to be a
close button or
we need to set focus by default on an
element when the dialog appears and you
need to do maintains have order within
the dialogue and I have an example for
that too you'll notice when this dialog
opened up I set focus immediately on the
username element and if you tried having
through it keeps focus within the tab
over here you'll see those setting the
role dialogue I'm sitting I'm using the
two required REO properties which point
to the title of the form and the
description here
another comment role you use is
navigation and our native apartments for
this one but if you use like the show
you this type of navigation menu then
what you want to you want to use these
properties in state so Aria controls
associate control with the elements that
okay
in this case that menu
similarly the Aria owns it finds a
parent-child relationship and helps us
let you know that this element owns the
submenu and in the example that I showed
you the elements are actually
technically sibling elements in the bomb
but by setting this re owns we let the
screen reader know that technically a
child or we wanted to be down the child
element also you could specify a hand
pop-up and this just let the screen
screen reader know that this sink has a
related pop up and aria-expanded is
actually applied to the sub menu itself
and you just set it to true when the
milk is being shown in aktau I'll show
you this example again
so I'm from using the nav element with
the role attribute and the menu link
here has RF controls in our own set to
the sub menus which is an
my set has pop up to true and my sub
menu has re-expanded set to false and I
test them simple JavaScript on here that
toggles that property based on the
visibility it's technically a sangwich
another one easy 12 is the role starch
so this is going to be your search form
on your website and there is no
requirement but a useful aria-label a
useful properties erl label so this is
um what works Sir Tom looks like and we
actually use this arrow icon to indicate
for the submit button and you'll see I'm
using the role search here on the form
tag and then i'm using our a legal here
what I don't want is a screen reader to
read out you know la it's not going to
make any sim city whose
so by specifying this aria-label it'll
actually when it gets focus it will
actually say semester which makes much
more sense to user
mixed up as a real form or form role and
the only requirement is already
described by that should just point to
the element ID to an ID for the element
that is for artisan form form validation
this is what not to do you don't want to
decide like the elements in red because
that doesn't make sense to be to the
screen reader you need to give some
textual indication that the form is
invalid and there's also these other
elements that you can for attributes
that you can set so are required will
you add that to the input element set
that's a true is required re invalid you
set this after you run validation and
you can set that to true false and
grammar error you can finish primer is
it with binary to set its fine another
useful property is our
everybody else and an example for that
is we use asterisk a lot to indicate
when a field is required and you can
just hide that for screen readers
because a screen reader will actually
say asterisk or star but since we're
since you should be studying all
required anyway the user is going to
know that it's required so you don't
need to you know you don't need to rita
hester is all out after you run
validation you just meet set focus on
the first invalid element set ra invalid
to true and add a description that at an
error message with the bro allure and of
course i have an example
so this is just a really simple form i'm
using the aria labeled by to point to
the title of my former and i'm using the
required I are described by two points
of the instructions this is the asterisk
so I'm setting that I'm using Aria
hidden true here so that screen readers
will just skip over it for the input
fields i'm setting our i require to true
and then asked once i run validation I'm
displaying this error message here and
that's the span here with the row alert
and I'm doing this two different ways so
one way to do it is to actually invest
it inside the label tag and what's going
to happen is once it receives focus and
the screen reader will read the label
first then the error then indicate to
the user that the echo place within a
text box that's required and invalid a
second approach is sometimes your design
doesn't allow you to actually include
that error message within the label so
sup its second approach that you can use
is to add and carry on
re required sorry re labeled by property
to your input element and set that to
the ID of your error message and that
will have a similar behavior
and set with the last example some tools
i use were wave and the chrome
accessibility developer tools will
basically allow you to run an audit on
your webpage and their screen readers i
use for this for chrome box which is
with nice and easy because it's an
extension in chrome and voiceover that
comes with all output devices and they
were actually really different so and my
references were the mdn spelling docks
and the w3c aria that's any questions
actually go back to the first
so I have a question and I think you may
have talked a little bit about this in
the first five we're out what yeah but
so what kind of people are you targeting
this for and do sites that are like more
visual and creative kind of oriented
need to incorporate as much of this yeah
so this is basically everybody that
doesn't use a mess that will use
primarily a scream uterus or some sort
of assistive technology so this helps
premiers identify important areas of the
page and sections of a page and the
roles are important too because
most of these assistive technologies
allow users to navigate a page based on
rule so that would be one reason like
people that rely on shortcuts on a
keyboard they'll be able to you know use
a shortcut to get directly to the main
content or to a navigational myth
do you know what screen readers are
heavily used these days I know jaws is
heavily used in the past but I don't
know what's current the job is still
primarily used on t please I but I don't
know the number sorry
what is testing look like for this in
your development cycle what are some God
you still exploring I mean and we use
selenium where work so we're definitely
look I think there are a few sliding the
toll booth will be able to use to be
sure but right now I'm just doing that
you know just manual validation using
way the tools i haven't actually some
idea of making this part of a work for
was just kind of learning enough like I
don't ask for permission to to go in and
it feels good styles include HTML
semantic so we're trying to make this
part of my workflow or I kind of have
these attributes memorized and I don't
actually need to spend time looking at
documents to try to figure out what do I
need to use and I don't meet then use
that like s permission my product
manager
for it but once I get this going I do
have as part of our QA team to to look
into tools I do wonder think that seems
like an opportunity for an automated
tool that
they're probably you sling in to press
things and then it would tell you what
it says out loud and you think you have
a script that's what you expect it to
say out loud seems like a bit of
something for us right now are
translated like six different languages
did you make a robot but we sure it's
saying the right things into our video
you don't want to be saying arrow you
want to be saying I think they are much
different we talked about this earlier
they all have like that they all into
very verb browser wars early differences
or at different Skinner's a ticket
you need to use IVC cross-reference
elements yeah you allow those all those
properties to more than one ID too so
you can space the limit
and what I've been doing is for like
four tooltips where I might have two
paragraphs I just wrapped them in one
element and use that one ID for the two
paragraph elements
but yeah
this shadow Dom you can use ideas again
yeah yeah that's better that's the
awesome thing we will be able to spill
these components and make them
accessible I'm useful just curiously
foreign language speaking
I haven't um
and as you know you know yeah that's a
really good question they I don't like I
didn't actually look into like this
voiceover speak Spanish I but yeah I'll
try it out some curious what line of
business your company is in and that it
makes sense for the company to go to the
expense of implementing okay because I
understand that in a perfect world would
be wonderful if the entire internet
works that work this way but it for
companies that aren't required legal
perspective this yes I heard or anything
publisher like they don't think we need
to do this at all I'm just kind of doing
this like it we just started a new ember
app and I had the output so we're
building a lot of our what we're
traditionally jquery UI components and
remote
and other components now and we're
working with your career you I gets a
little hairy so what I've done is I'm
building these prototypes excessively
and they're being reused across our code
base which is awesome and you know it's
the type of thing like they're they're
an indie publisher we were primarily
print so they don't think we need to do
this I disagree so what I'm doing is I'm
just doing it but I'm not actually
taking a lot of time like I did the
research and I know what I need to do to
make things accessible i'm sure i'm
missing a few things here and there and
then i'm giving feedback and forward bus
when I see like someone adds dialogue on
my own you know if you have these two
attributes you can make a style of
accessible that's your project taken
because Michael Page is not been going
to do you know what the regulations or
I think our website since be accessible
I think india countries make making the
trip public services when i worked at
sears a few years ago sway how to panic
about
just as it was a little bit my own
opinions I don't I like to use the
keyboard a lot like a lot if I never had
to switch my hand to the mouse i would
be happy and a lot of these things
really help with that because you can't
add and close a modal so it's not just
the conf call the gigantic costs of
being able to support people who won't
be only use joysticks or with their
mouths or something like that there
there are real world normal houston
support and if you use jquery UI j crew
you eyes already accessible completely
and that's actually where I you know
kind of sanity checks against what Jake
who you are
another it's kind of a weird option but
enjoy a slow because a widget library is
actually open source and usable on the
web down and I know that when I was
developing Windows 8 apps I saw a bunch
of Aria attributes scattered all
throughout the DOM and so it's similar
to jquery why well learning or if you
happen to like that look I think the
coach also yeah so honey on
accessibility for free hide I haven't
verified by her Twitter bootstrap comes
pre defined with area attributes so you
get some minimal by default
accessibility yeah
one thing that bugs me too is when
people remove the focus highlight stuff
so I you know where you're at sorry have
we have for talks